okay the time being
10:04 I'm going to convene uh this
meeting of the commission on worldwide
combined reporting for unitary
businesses under the business profits
tax uh we are expecting representative
oler will attend this morning and that
would give us our and here he is and we
now have a
quarum I'm one sentence in
Jordan and we know that Mr Kennedy is
not present um but he of course has
reviewed the report drafts and will
weigh in subsequent to this
meeting we've uh we have
minutes uh for three
meetings and I'd like to begin by
reviewing those so we have the minutes
for the meeting of October 2nd October
17th and October
23rd and uh has everyone had a chance to
review the minutes
are we prepared to make a motion to
accept the minutes of October
2nd I'm sorry I'll make a motion to
approve a minute okay motion from
representative
shamberg second second Senator
Murphy all those in favor please
indicate by saying I I any opposed no
there were two typos that uh
representative shamberg will correct not
worth not worth talking about um then we
have the minutes of October
17th and the only change I've requested
is there's a reference in parentheses in
the draft on page two to attach is oral
presentation for commission that'll be
deleted so we're not going to add uh
notes of an oral oral um
presentation okay do we have any
questions on these
minutes ready for a
motion thank you motion from Senator
Murphy second from representative erery
all those in favor signify by saying I I
any
opposed minutes of October 17th are
accepted and third uh we have the M
minutes from October 23rd prepared by uh
representative alri
and uh they are brief and succinct any
questions okay I'll second that motion
we have a motion from the master on this
one and a second all those in favor I
and
opposed okay great it's always nice to
start with minutes and we've got
momentum okay
um
I sent out a um update on Friday
morning
further uh last evening around
7 and then a final around 11: that
incorporated very few changes I can
point to in the event that anyone didn't
see uh what went out that
late
um I think our business for
today is to take any comments any disc
discussion regarding the draft um and uh
also we can uh uh turn to representative
shamber uh at a appropriate point for
any comments he wants to make regarding
his Minority Report yes representative H
um I thank the chair for putting
together a pretty good uh a very good um
historical analysis of both the uh uh
issue in front of us and the actions of
this particular commit Mission
appreciate that I think that for the
remainder of the day if we begin in page
eight because everything prior to that
yes is historical yes uh I don't without
an object if there's an
objection I think that's a I think
that's a good plan I would just ask
quickly we have now had
the process and procedures and the
testimony and record in front of of us
from a PRI meeting there were very small
edits that were essentially grammatical
typ of spelling I'm very much thank uh
Keen W for contributing to to that
editing process and I found a whole
bunch of my own but unless there are any
specific questions relating to the uh uh
testimony and
record I just look for those first and
then I agree with representative ol we
can jump to page eight where the
findings
begin okay we're all set then on the
process and on the uh
Records representative Alie and
following up on that discussion it it
appears the way that this is a Manu or
was created is that there is a finding
and there's a historical analysis of the
finding and I think that the historical
analysis there may be a word or two here
but the historical analysis is pretty St
stated and the finding itself the bolded
areas the one the numerical numbers the
bullet points um are the ones that we
should P primarily focus on okay good
point yeah and I would
uh I would just point out I think it's
obvious to those of us who uh members
who've been reading this but for the
record the purpose and the testimony and
record are intended to be completely
neutral just
narrative uh the
findings represent conclusions of the
commission at large uh so they make
judgments but they're judgments as to
which we I believe have come to a
consensus in fact I believe the minority
um is is probably in Harmony and will
let us know if he's not uh on the
findings so the findings are
organized around the draft that Mr Foley
and Mr Kennedy
prepared uh to you know represent the
filtered
conclusions of the commission as to the
State of Affairs the landscape within
which we're examining this um they are
not intended to be you know
argumentative and I think that they're
not
controversial in contrast if you jump
over
to
page 15 the analysis which was added
yesterday and the recommendations which
were added Friday
morning are the judged conclusions of
the
majority and would be in contrast to the
position of the minority
okay is that fairly fairly delineated so
with uh with that let somebody else
wants to make General comments let's
just go to page
nine and as uh representative ol has
suggested let's just
read each bolded
finding and we won't wait into the
discussion unless somebody points to
something that they
question is that good before you go on
yes representative shamber yes
uh I sent a final
draft to Jen with
attachments will those be
distributed electronically or should we
do it
paperwise I think if we could have a
printed copy here with us this morning
that would be great good glad to know
that's in sent right you sent it to J so
we haven't seen it but we will see it
it's basically the things that we've
covered and where would that go into
this report it won't go into the
memorandum it'll be included in the
reports right yes I'm going to ask Jen
to help me make sure this is formatted
correctly but this 16-page document that
we have in front of us will be the
commission's report okay the
commission's report will include The
Minority Report as the first ATT
attachment and it will include the
bibliography now the the narratives on
page uh um 2
to8 addresses basically the the
testimony uh and uh the record from
those who appeared before
us there are references to other
collateral documents court cases
articles in the findings all of which
and many more of those are included in
the
bibliography and unless the commission
members ask and decide to do this it's
not currently my intent to attach any
collateral documents like articles or
cases to the report but rather to let
the bibliography lead anybody who wants
to go further to find them okay
representative
Valerie like you
one or two
papers had a little
practice and I noticed there were no
footnotes that's true so rather than the
footnoting we're putting this in the uh
um biblography at the end yes that's a
very good point
so references I did not write this like
a legal brief right uh where we cited a
court case I do give in parentheses in
where we've quoted a given parentheses
the actual citation of that volume and
page for the US Supreme Court or for the
New Hampshire Supreme Court with respect
to those who testified in the record the
references and the quotes are all to the
body of what they physically presented
to us and that's in the record which of
course is also accessible on the general
Court's
website um as far as external articles
are referred to the article the citation
itself is in the bibliography and so
there was no effort to uh indicate where
a quote came from a particular page but
there is an effort to uh indicate what
uh speaker or what document that came
from but so the the citations I think
are loose in terms of you know if you
compare this to a legal uh opinion or a
scholarly article but uh but I believe
that they all do lead you exactly to
where those quotes came from yes Mr Wong
thank you chair I just have a quick
question on the um the attachment that
was sent out by Jen on Friday from
representative shanberg on the glossery
of terms how is that going to be
incorporated into the uh the report I
haven't seen
that that's one I was sent that last
week on Friday yeah
sen she'll be bringing it in okay we'll
see that in a little bit and then I
think can we Circle back to your
question I did not send direct to you I
sent I sent anything to Jen to send it
out whether she did or okay well that's
not something that I've seen but we will
see it this morning and so we can Circle
back right okay good so
um and we don't need to labor this more
than you want to since you've all read
it uh but uh in fact yeah I don't think
I need to actually read the bolded part
but let's go to number one the the point
here is that while there was a statute
on the books from 81 to 86 on worldwide
combined reporting that was never
implemented and so there is no actual
pre precedent for um this program in the
state despite the fact that it was on
the books are we good with that
yes Mr Wong um thank you chair so um I'm
just going into the uh the the
discussion in the uh below the bullet
point or below the bould boulder Point
um and I think it's uh based on the the
memo and this is in regards to New
Hampshire um not enforcing the um the
worldwide combined reporting in terms in
relations to uh foreign based multi
Corporation the letter of commissioner
price from had the letter from
commissioner price to the a white
unitary taxation World working group
task force back in
1983 um so I think that's fine because
that's what's stated in in the letter um
I just wanted to check if um later down
on the in the middle of the uh the
section in the paragraph where it says
uh in the testimony from commissioner uh
commissioner price back in
1986 on the implementation of the the
waterers Edge limitation says right
wrong or indifferent and then in in
Brackets in parenthesis the Dr never did
go totally worldwide um we never did tax
foreign dividends from foreign parents
uh we never tax foreign parents um so I
wonder if if that would was me to say um
like New Hampshire never did go
worldwide supposed to the Dr never did
go totally worldwide um not sure if
that's uh more accurate are you asking
what's the we he's referring to yeah so
the in in parenthesis the Dr never did
go worldwide so I wonder if that's
that's an added term in there from the
testimony okay so so this is a direct
quote but you'll see in bracket the Dr
yeah because the word he used is we and
I just inserted using brackets the Dr
because that's what he meant by wi okay
I was wondering if he meant the New
Hampshire never did go worldwide totally
because that's what's his written
testimony was in he he did mean New
Hampshire but are you saying that you
think it should be stated New Hampshire
instead of the Dr that's my thought I'm
not the state rather than the the agency
yeah okay I'm fine with that what does
the letter say itself it says uh on
point number five New Hampshire takes
the position that since the United
States Supreme Court has never yet ruled
on the constitutionality of subjecting a
foreign based multinational corporation
doing business in the United States to
worldwide combined reporting it will not
require nor accept a petition to file a
combined report let's just be clear that
that the the first of the quotes the one
you've just read again yeah comes from
the letter dated November 30th 1983
that's right and that's clearly cited
here Y and the second quote comes from
his testimony before the house Ways and
Means Committee on February 20th 1986
right right so I think the only question
you're asking is where we're picking up
on his quote and it's saying we that you
feel more comfortable inserting that we
means New Hampshire yeah so I'm not I
wasn't present at that time I'm not sure
if he meant we as in the Dr or as in the
state I I don't need I don't think it
makes a big difference but I believe he
was speaking as commissioner for the
agency right yeah so we know we know
what the law said yeah but the agency
took a position and it wasn't even
really just a matter of interpretation
it was a matter of policy
restraint not to enforce in a way that
was going to
attract constitutional litigation and
not to enforce in a way that was going
to attract Congressional preemption at
the the federal level it's an an
interesting instance of an agency saying
we see what the law says but we aren't
going there yeah Mr
chairman Mr price was no longer
commissioner at that time Mr ever Taylor
was commissioner at that time
so he had been appointed he he had I
think he's speaking about the past tense
of this we never as a state back then
did it yes
yes and I think that's clear is that
clear that yes all right
um Mr chair I I can clarify if he was no
longer in the position that's easy to do
yeah then okay yeah okay good I'll make
that
change all right so the second nothing
uh moving to worldwide combined
reporting would not be constitutionally
borrowed so we have a constitutional
discussion that takes in the container
and Barkley cases uh before the US
Supreme Court I've added a quote from
Justice Brennan's majority opinion last
night which is uh colorful and um I just
thought that this uh really adds to the
P you our sense of what the court was
thinking
allocating income among various taxing
jurisdictions Bears some resemblance as
we have emphasized throughout this
opinion to slicing a shadow in the
absence of a central coordinating
Authority absolute consistency even
among taxing authorities whose basic
approach to the task is quite similar
may just be too much to
ask so I think that there's often a
sense amongst um
Layman that uh the Commerce Clause of
the 14th amendment
requires absolute zero
discrimination but this quote and the
quote in the next paragraph from the New
Hampshire Supreme Court's caterpillar
decision are put in here to reflect the
fact that the courts acknowledge that
there's differential
treatment but they come to the
conclusion that that differential
treatment is within a the range of
reasonable Behavior behavior and is not
therefore discriminatory in the
Constitutional
sense discriminatory in the
Constitutional sense is not an absolute
term that requires that there be zero
differentiation so in the next quote you
see the latter
part it says
uh the plaintiffs fail however to meet
their burden in proving
discrimination and uh although New
Hampshire's unitary apportionment
formula may not apportion income
perfectly the Federal Constitution does
not require a mathematical exactitude
only a rough
approximation so they had said in the
earlier part of that that merely
acknowledging that there is differential
treatment does not rise to a
constitutional problem with
discrimination I thought these two
quotes added a good bit to u to our
narrative and the justices were speaking
federally correct in the first quote at
the top of page 10 that's Justice branon
uh which is indicated at the bottom of
page nine for the Supreme Court in the
quotation set off in the middle of page
10 uh that's the New Hampshire Supreme
Court in caterpillar
okay
okay all right uh anything further on
this constitutional BAS basically what
the Constitutional discussion says is
we're not constrained one way or the
other that isn't the
problem okay number three simple and
declarative transfer pricing
exists I've added uh there are four
paragraphs here three of these were
provided by um Matt and Kevin Mr Foley
Mr Kennedy excuse me and then I added
the second paragraph Yes yesterday the
purpose of the second paragraph is to
reflect the comments that Mr Kennedy was
making at the end of our meeting last
week and I'll just read them quickly it
must be emphasized that transfer pricing
is not inherently bad in fact it's
actually necessary and even mandatory it
is common in distributing the economic
burdens for shared economic benefits
across a range of Affiliated entities of
a variety of expenses or Investments
incurred for research and development
intellectual property shared brand
development and marketing and a broad
range of other expenditures particularly
intangibles these are the same sort of
benefits procured at a cost from
non-affiliated or arms length suppliers
of goods and services a clear analogy
can be found in the normal practice of
franchise operations in which the
franchisee contractually commits to
share in a variety of expenses and
Investments made by the franchise or so
that's new language as of last night
Mr Foley does that fit with everything
that you've
okay good sorry labor that I just wanted
to you know I did say in my memo last
night that anything that got added late
on I would point
to so we're good with three number four
transfer pricing May create an unlevel
playing
field and I think this is very uh
important because three and four
acknowledge core beliefs of the
proponents of worldwide combined
reporting these are
truths yes representative Valerie while
it's unknown what level exists I believe
we also discuss that it's
unknowable
correct correct and um in number six
you'll find that the caption has been uh
amended to include the last three words
method is unknown and probably
unknowable and I'm just suggesting that
perhaps in uh par paragraph three that
uh in the U second sentence at the
beginning it is unknown comma and
unknowable and likely
unknowable I'm fine with that everyone
else and likely
unknowable sounds
good so that's in the first paragraph of
uh item four in the fourth
line
see yours is on
four says three are you using the same
sheet as the rest of
us Jordan your papers are down there
that's the last
version that seems to be where you've
been hanging
out sorry I thought that was your
address that was a very funny joke Mr
chairman
okay if you're saying it was in number
three all I I went around the corner of
my barn during the weekend when I was
doing yard work and on the back door of
an unoccupied Barn I found a FedEx
package at the door it was addressed to
somebody with a different number on a
different
street so I took it over to her so we we
got to stay on our toes so it's going to
be on number four it's number four okay
all right there we go thank you D
you all right uh so to the top of page
12 item
five um New Hampshire currently taxes
for an income generated by businesses
subject to the business profits
tax so this hits the foreign dividends
and the
guilty not to C some words here but it
says taxes foreign income is generated
by business subject to the business
profits tax that would be only us
multinational corporations here in the
United States are subject to this
correct you saying all porn income
generated
All
Foreign Mr Foley help me with this it's
all foreign income that is repatriated
to the United
States and I could imagine that a
foreign parent might have a subsidiary
in the United States that might have a
further sub subsidiary in a foreign
country so I think generalizing doesn't
work it's it's from any of these uh
foreign Affiliates of a unitary
group to the extent that the funds are
repatriated into the
US okay is that fair okay I so I believe
we're accurately stated
okay yes representative yeah and at the
same time we do not need to continually
use New Hampshire because somebody
created a glossery of
terms without uh that was part of mine
yeah yeah
and I I think that glosy of terms is
something that uh should be lted just a
little bit or comment made as to its
appropriateness to for
inclusion okay so you'll address that in
a little bit or you want to address it
right now okay just saying this is a
good place for
it it came to the front of my mind so I
said it yes
and represent Senator shamber let's pass
these out while we're referring to
it last p in I think
is okay and representative oler have you
had a chance to read this Glasser I
glanced over it last night yeah and does
it look good to
you didn't that I okay first re exam so
arms length principle unitary business
principle worldwide combined reporting
waterers Edge combined
reporting and we had some discussion
last week on that kind of uh topic about
the use of the term transfer pricing
which is a term of Art in the accounting
World versus
using certain other terms like profit
shifting or abusive that you'll find in
quotes in several places where they've
been used so where an advocate has used
them it's part of what they told us
where the report uses those terms there
in
quotations and as we learned the
transfer price uh the soall transfer
pricing is merely the transfer of a
fungible um resource available to any
Corporation engaged in that particular
activity it's not done by a particular
corporation for particular purpose
exactly it's it's it's an accounting
entry
and usually a transfer of funds between
Affiliated
entities okay um finding number six the
revenue impact of changing to the
worldwide combined reporting method is
yes
represent are we gon just for the
minutes here where are we going to
include this will just be are we going
to include those definitions in there is
that what you want no okay thank you
that's
good okay yep so finding number six uh
any comments
here and again this
uh We've added the words and probably
unknowable Mr je yes this particular
paragraph does uh clear out the uh
confusion or not confusion it eliminates
any source of confusion that the
transfer the transfer pricing is purely
for X purpose as opposed to merely
existing thank you okay yes I think
that's certainly the
purpose okay other
questions now um
finding number seven uh was newly
included
yesterday uh and uh so this goes beyond
the portion of the findings that were
prepared by Mr fly Mr Kennedy and comes
from our
discussions at least four other states
in the past half dozen years or so have
evaluated proposals to adopt wwcr and
have rejected these proposals so this is
a very brief r view of recent
um uh proposals that were in the state
of Indiana Minnesota Maine and Rhode
Island and uh the purpose here is to
reflect that the commission is well
aware of proposals and discussions in
other states we're not
alone also to
distinguish those proposals from what's
being
uh considered here and characterize them
very briefly in about a sentence each
and ultimately to draw the conclusion
that in the 40 years or so that uh uh
that we're talking about there has been
no state that has reverted to worldwide
combined reporting and no current
momentum in that
direction Al are we set on that
one and finally uh finding eight also
has been added uh to reflect the
commission's discussions the commission
has heard of no credible methodology for
effectively estimating the potential
state tax revenue to be gained from
wwcr and has concluded that any
estimates of which we are aware
represent broad conjecture without a
sound factual
foundation and this
cites the study by uh Institute on
Taxation and economic policy itep as
well as the rebuttal
from the tax
Foundation anybody who wants to delve
into this there's direct citations of
those
articles and uh it does not attempt to
um weigh in on and participate in the
debate just to draw the conclusion that
there is no consensus on how a State
might even rationally approach an effort
to estimate the impact on potential tax
revenues may I bring something up
it you said it has re it is not there is
no conclusion yet the statement has has
heard of no credible
methodology doesn't that say
that the reports that have been uh
developed are you saying that they are
not
credible yes and you're saying that the
tax foundations the tax found
foundation's position is the credible
one that's that's the impression I'm
getting here yes on the first no on the
second
so what this says it reflects certainly
my conclusion that the tax Foundation
has
effectively
demolished the itep estimates what the
tax Foundation has not done is
identified an alternative method so
what's been
offered as estimates are not
credible and we lack any credible
alternative we don't
have um the commission has heard of no
credible
methodology and has concluded any
estimates of which we're aware represent
broad conve conjecture without a sound
factual foundation so it's it's not that
the tax Foundation has given us a way of
estimating it's simply shown us that one
particular effort to
estimate um doesn't cut
it the words that the tax Foundation
used I
believe they used words versus
finding the methodology of the it or uh
any other
methodology they have shown where is
that methodology wrong I don't think
they've shown that the tax Foundation
that's why I I just sort of disagree
with the when you say no credible
methodology you're taking
one organization that says this
methodology is completely wrong it
doesn't doesn't have its foundations
downright uh maybe it's the word no
credible methodology that's got me stuck
on this right now because I believe that
the methodologies
are are appropriate or are good until
someone can actually show
using data using a methodology to show
me why is it wrong why is it not so I
think we have two two choices here um
one is uh you know again the the
certainly it's been the effort to make
sure that the
findings speak for all of us but uh um
this is uh you know perhaps one of those
things that representative shamberg may
want to address in his Minority Report
if the rest of us agree on the other
hand if we want to make a modification
we can do that so I look to other
members to react to What representative
shamberg has just said um my personal
view
is the tax found foundation's analysis
of the itep
estimates is absolutely
convincing and demonstrates that the ITP
effort is not
credible and that's what this finding is
intending to say that's fairly strong
but it it's not so much that we're
trying to
indict uh itep or any particular effort
it's simply to say that as we look
across the um you know the universe we
see nothing that gives us something that
we could actually utilize and rely
upon okay representative all did want to
add no the the line the sentence that
you just used sounds like something that
um if you can remember
it uh might resolve the uh arguments
that representative shamberg is
attempting to to raise here uh as that
it indicates This research versus that
research This research resounds better
than that
research and that may just be
phraseology that would be appropriate
sir so I'm willing to uh
um look at softening the words a little
bit so it doesn't sound like it's
intended to be damning
but uh before I do that representative
shamberg would that satisfy you
or if you can make it not sound so as
you say
damaging because I I I remember us we
had a
um Michael maerov gave us a piece when
he was talking about profit let see here
this is this is in a private I mean a
prior session of the yeah legislature he
had mentioned that
independent California estimate a
potential gain from the wwcr is actually
larger than the it study so there's
other studies out
there somehow if we
can make this as you say not so damaging
so um the maerov I'm I'm aware of him
and some of his work just from the
collateral readings I've done but it's
not part of the record of this
commission and uh that doesn't preclude
you from from mentioning it in your
minority but you would want to indicate
you know where you're drawing that
information
from do you
have give me a moment uh here to just
look at
it
well is are we hung up on the word
credible or is it deeper than that no I
think how about
workable sounds good okay everyone's
okay all
right good then um thank
you so I I think that uh for anybody who
you know is coming to this uh
commission's report from the
outside and uh they're looking at it you
know to really pick the meat out of it
and scan through it they jump right past
the findings and testimon I mean that
rather the testimony and record and they
come to these bolded passages and they
just read the eight findings I think
they get a very good idea of what we
determined and again I want to give a
lot of thanks to uh Mr Foley and Mr
Kennedy for helping us shape that
up um now the uh I think that the
remaining part of the findings are less
likely to require discussion but uh
let's just quickly so the mitigating
factors are the reduction of the federal
corporate tax rate from 35 to 21 and the
introduction of guilty that both
occurred in
2017 as part of the tax cuts and jobs
act um the third grouping is the uh
arguments in support
against uh I believe these are virtually
unedited from uh the draft provided by
Mr Foley and Mr Kennedy and I'm s
satisfied with those as being a very
crisp reduction not all Arguments for
and against but those that uh that are
substantive and
pivotal now that takes us to the
analysis now of course the analysis is
where we actually take a stand as a
commission and this is where um the U
Minority Report will diverge um I tried
to be uh very brief
and uh just you know bring it down to uh
to rationale so not to repeat what's
already been stated in the findings and
so we have uh what two five
paragraphs um I did a little bit of
addition to this last
night um I would point in particular to
the last paragraph that's completely new
last night all methods of apportionment
just like Geographic or separate entity
accounting are
imperfect that's essentially what the
courts um from Brennan's passage and
from the New Hampshire caterpillar case
passage acknowledge they are proxies
devices methodologies for triangulating
in on a fair share taxation they all
embody trade-offs and merely pointing to
a flaw or limitation in any one method
does not signify that any the other
method will achieve a better result
there will be tradeoffs there will be
winners and losers amongst taxpayers and
there will be gains and losses for the
state but there's no generalization that
will forecast reasonably how these will
play out in practice prospectively at
the end of the discussion on balance the
commission finds that there is
insufficient evidence to make such a
radical change in New Hampshire's
business tax policy as
wwcr given the many implications clearly
present on the other side of of the
equation okay does anybody have anything
to add subtract or change from the
analysis and the
recommendations uh the purpose is to be
absolutely succinct number one we
recommend that New Hampshire not proceed
with wwcr
and therefore not with HB
1221 and we acknowledge in the second
recommendation while the commission does
not recommend further study at this
time the commission notes that there may
in the future be alternative means
available to the state of New Hampshire
to address the incentives a unitary
business might have to abuse transfer
pricing methods for the purpose of
Shifting tax this is again I think very
much trying to incorporate uh Mr
Kennedy's very constructive comment that
we go One Step Beyond merely saying
don't adopt worldwide combin reporting
and acknowledge that there may still be
developments in the future that we
become aware of especially if there is
leadership at the federal
level yes Mr Wong um this is a question
from a uh process standpoint so the Dr
being neutral and not having a position
on either way um whe going with
Worldwide combin reporting or not and
then the U the recommendations and the
analysis of the report is mainly
proposing to
um to that that's not sufficient
information to change the
um uh the current I guess taxing
position uh for for business profits tax
purposes
um I I
believe
um
I might have to just check in but just
in case if if we find that if Dr thinks
that we're not able to sort
of stand in that position because just
to that might uh that
might might sort of put us in a position
to say that oh uh the Dr does not
approve of worldwide combined reporting
so we're not sort of jeopardizing our
neutral position H how would we go about
doing that okay that's a very good
question it's one I've been anticipating
um and uh I think maybe it would be a
good idea for me to phone and have a
brief conversation with commissioner
stepp just to make sure I I know exactly
uh how she uh feels about It ultimately
it's your judgment I think that uh on
one hand you wear the hat of the dr's
representative on the other hand you're
a member of the commission who's
participated in the findings if you come
to the
conclusion that let's just say for
example that the drra stands behind
every aspect of the
report accepting that it takes no stance
on the recommendation itself I think a
supplemental statement to that
effect would just be
attached
right think think of it this way in a
court uh you have a majority position
you have a minority you also have what
are called concurring opinions right uh
and sometimes uh concurring opinions say
I uh you know um agree in part and
descent in part whatever so so I think
you can
qualify uh your signing on still
represents the U report of the
commission representative Valerie if if
I may address Mr Wong
um having seen the reports and of other
commissions and participated in other
commissions agencies routinely
participating commissions because of
the effect of what that Commission
report may have upon the operation of
the agency within the state un and it is
understood that the agency does what the
agency's told to do by
law the only thing that the agency is
doing is making input as to
their understanding of the effects not
whether they agree or dis disagree but
their understanding of the effects so
when if you sign off on this report with
or without a modification you're only
signing off that the agency has made
input this and the agency agrees with
the general analysis not that they are
advocating for one position or the other
position particularly since we have an
opposing position present so I think
that's valuable and key not to twist
your arm one way or the other but um I
defer to the Judgment that you reach uh
with the commissioner but I would
suggest just keep in mind our
recommendation does not recommend action
it recommends not action right so you I
I think there is there is a way in which
it could be viewed as a neutral position
to not change current law and uh you
know and we're also not recommending
some specific follow on representative
shamberg when you said does not
recommend action it says here we
recommend that the pending Bill be voted
inexpedient to legislate does that put
the Dr into a a position that maybe
should be discussed with the
commissioner well that's precisely what
we just said it it puts them in a
position of discussing it with the
commissioner and deciding what they're
comfortable
with so if when we vote
today will the Dr have to make a vote
vote on what's here right
now yes because other we don't have
a the answer is yes I'm going to ask
everyone for an approval of the report
subject to several edits that we've made
and if the drra then feels that it needs
to qualify uh its position it can do
that uh with a supplemental statement
that will be incorporated in just as The
Minority Report will be is that fair
yeah
okay okay so we we've we've marched
through the findings the analysis and
the recommendations but let's just pause
and uh take in further comments I know
there's got to be some yes Mr W just one
more comment uh back to point number six
um the revenue impact of the worldwide
combine reporting uh for a point a um
says that the Dr does not have the
capability to determine the uh the
amount of tax generated by the state's
current method of taxing foreign income
um not sure if if the uh the word
capability is um an accurate
representation uh is that the certain
fields in the um in the form are not
currently mapped by the system and so
um if we map those fields be able to
um calculate the the tax impact but
currently it's not mapped and if we do
it now we won't have the data from the
previous uh returns that we submitted
you you're M you're making a a good
technical Point um so this is on page 12
6A um and and you're highlighting the
capability maybe it's not a lack of
capability but a lack of I'm glad to
have you supply me some words that would
make this more specifically accurate I
just a little editorial
sidebar nothing's impossible right I was
horrified when I was reading the Rhode
Island uh study this 90 page study at
what they did to their taxpayers
apparently if I'm understanding it
correctly they required every business
tax filer in Rhode Island to prepare two
additional Pro
forers so that's a unitary filing state
and for two tax years as a Prelude to
the study their way of trying to get you
know the data that we were discussing
before was to require the the the filers
to prepare three tax
returns and file one as their official
return and file two more on an
information basis just so that the state
could get data and start to track it I
mean wow that if that was something that
somebody here proposed I would be an
absolute hell
no yes representative oler uh would
representative would Mr Wong be um
um amiable to inserting the word
currently in that sentence which
indicates possibility of future
modification right uh probably something
like currently unable to fully determine
um yes the amount
um uh of tax generated by the state's
current method of tax so the New
Hampshire Department of Revenue
Administration is not currently able is
that where you're going yeah it's not
currently able to fully determine uh the
amount of tax
generated
so we're we're merely striking out does
not have the capability and putting in
instead is not currently
able that's fine with
me representative Valery no that's oh
okay that was an accent Ascent
okay
good well thank you for giving me the
latitude to do a lot of drafting against
thank you to Mr foing Mr Kennedy for
giving me the meat of the
findings
um I'll look around once more to see if
there are further comments and uh then
I'll turn it over to representative
shamberg for anything he might want to
say I haven't read his current uh report
but it stands on its own it's his
document so representative
shamberg thank you Mr chairman and I'd
like to
first of all thank all the members of
the commission for finding the time
and and the research they did in for
this worldwide combined reporting
commission uh I'd like to thank the
chair for undertaking the organization
of this commission
report uh and to thank Jen for for her
guidance as we stumbled along
uh one of the items that was just
delivered is the minority
position uh it's a
seven page seven pages long and I do not
think there was much change other
than I can't remember any of the changes
I made from the original one but this is
the one I would like to
submit along with the
attachments uh that Jen capably ran off
uh the caterpillar
decision
the uh Lloyd Price letter the letter
from uh AI Yohan of Michigan law
concerning uh questions that were asked
about
reporting and the
glossery two-sided page the arms length
principal the unitary business principal
worldwide combined reporting and
waterers Edge combined reporting just
wanted to make sure that this is
somewhere
attached uh that's that's fine I have no
objection to the attachments I would
just make parenthetical comment here
there is a letter dated October 18th uh
heading Michigan law University of
Michigan
from ruven aona yeah it's addressed to
me but uh first time I've seen it is uh
is when representative shamberg asked
genen 4 to circulate it so was it was
not directed to me although it is
addressed on the page to me
so okay and
concerning I'm sorry what okay
concerning uh the report today I had uh
developed a response
from a little excerpt from an earlier
note you sent out to us and I did not
see your final report till 9:15 last
night when I had finished my so but I
think I hit the points that you have
brought up today uh in regard to The
Minority Report versus various position
statements of the
majority The Minority Report responds
that there is a flaw in the waters edge
method that shows Dom domestic New
Hampshire businesses have been competing
at an economic disadvantage since 1986
with foreign multinational corporations
which allow these organizations to
reduce their tax liability no matter how
much business they do in the granite
state and as a result domestic companies
face a disportionate disproportionate
tax liability while the state is losing
Revenue to pay for State services and
what supports the minority position the
statements first the majority and
minority in statements and in written
form say that transfer pricing exist
that transfer pricing and profit
shifting exist but at an unknown levels
and amounts and that transfer pricing
May create an unlevel playing field the
second support statement from reporting
sources articles submitted for review by
this commission from the tax Justice
Network CNN tax games it and others
describing describe profit shifting to
tax havens of lower tax
liability a third source of support for
the minority
position is the IRS that just launched
ir-2 23-1 194 new initiatives using the
inflation reduction act funding to
ensure large corporations pay taxes owed
this includes large foreign owned
corporations transfer pricing initiative
these foreign companies report losses or
exceedingly low margins year after year
through the improper use of transfer
pricing to avoid reporting appropriate
amounts of us profits to the US
government if this is happening at the
federal level with these foreign
multinationals who have substantial
subsidiaries like New Hampshire does
with 424 at last count there is a saying
where there is smoke there is a
fire these mentioned sources from above
at least indicate there is an unlevel
playing field that can be applied to New
Hampshire domestic businesses who pay BP
taxes on 100% of their taxable profits
when the provisions of Water's Edge
allow foreign
multinationals with subsidiaries to
obscure the full picture of their
activities in New Hampshire and from the
Dr because these companies are not
required to account for their operations
outside the United States Beyond Water's
Edge my friend the chair of this
commission should have been a football
coach because of the plays that can be
called in a
game I knew I get knew I get a little a
of you one play that a coach that is
called by coach
is
misdirection getting players to go one
way while the ball carrier is going
another way in the 1999 caterpillar Inc
versus New Hampshire Dr the appeal
involved only questions of federal
constitutional law especially the
Commerce cause and if royalty and
interest payments by Foreign members to
domestic members are to be included as
income of the waters's edge group group
because they represent value earned by
The Waters Edge group that is not
otherwise captured the answer was it is
taxable and reported under the water's
edge and not in violation of the
Commerce cause yet the misdirection play
of the majority is trying to argue that
The Waters Edge method is not
unconstitutional in regard to foreign
affiliates with subsidiaries in the
United States the New Hampshire Supreme
Court said the nature of the Waters Edge
formula requires that foreign
subsidiaries be treated differently from
domestic subsidiaries most
significantly the latter income is
subject to taxation while the former's
income is not close quote the New
Hampshire Court also said in the same
case quote in 1986 the legislature
adopted The Waters Edge method
eliminated in overseas business
organizations from subjection to the
business profits tax close quote that is
why the fourth source of support for the
minority is the New Hampshire Supreme
Court when it said we point
out wat's edge method was adopted for
the benefit of foreign businesses prior
to
1986 New Hampshire utilized worldwide
combined reporting in which the net
income of all members of the unitary
group domestic and foreign was included
in the tax base close quotes it was
unfair for the state not to enforce the
worldwide combined reporting law from
1981 to
1986 the new law in 1986 The Waters Edge
seems to have changed an equal and Level
Playing Field law for all into an
unequal law for domestic
businesses that is why the minority is
saying that there is a competitive
disadvantage facing domestic companies
that is why there is a question of the
rule of law those domestic taxpayers of
BPT are treated differently from foreign
companies this is
unconstitutional the foreign
multinational company's competitive
Advantage by its very Nature has the
tendency to erode trust in the equity of
our government and thus in the
government itself making Waters Edge BPT
an unlevel playing field there should
not be tears in our tax system anymore
than there should be two tiers of
Justice this is
anti-democratic and anti-free market and
I appreciate you'll let me read that and
I'll make sure that I do send a copy on
to Jen so that she can or will this be
recorded anywhere else other than we are
recorded we are recording
Jen I will just make sure you get a copy
I believe we're recorded okay thank you
Mr chairman I hope you didn't mind me
saying you're a football coach or you
could have been a good
one I'll back my
time okay um this is why there's
opportunity for a Minority Report and I
do think that uh those who read both
will understand that there is a
different understanding of the reach of
the caterpillar decision for example um
any further
comments okay well I don't know exactly
what the protocol is with the commission
but I think I'm going to ask for a vote
to adopt the majority
report
yes um I would like to address some of
the uh the uh the text that's provided
in the glossery from uh representative
shamber if I may yes which I have not
even read yet
so and by the way our our deadline to
file is on Wednesday November 1st we
have several adits that we've already
discussed if there's something further
that somebody sees it can be brought up
and Incorporated within the next 48
hours but I would say it's Our intention
that we're basically
uh going to resolve whether this is a
finished product as closely as we can so
um with that comment um I this I feel
the same way about anything attached to
uh representative Schamberg's go feel
free to go ahead and address it um so
the the first point I want to to bring
up for discussion is the the I guess the
definition for the unitary business
principle um written here is the
principle is applicable to Corporation
that own and control subsidiaries for
tax purposes corporations and or taxing
authorities are allowed to treat
integrated Corporation with subsidiaries
as if a single taxable entity for tax
purposes the entire Enterprise
corporations and subsidiaries are taxed
as one um within the uh RSA
77-a um the BPT statute itself there is
a definition for unitary business in uh
77- a colon one
Roman 14 um and and it's defined that
within our statutes that a unitary
business means one or more related
business
organizations engaged in business
activity both within and without this
state among which there exists a Unity
of ownership operation and use or an
inter interdependence of in their
functions I was wondering if it's um
better in terms of uh not creating any
kind of source of
definition to that we replace the first
three sentences of this um in the
glossery with the exact definition from
the statute so it's not to create any
kind of confusion with with um or create
any yeah confusion with with taxpayers
tax preparers um
administrators so that the statutory
definition stands on its own and there's
nobody trying to figure out pars whether
they're the same or different uh without
having read these I just wonder first of
all um Jen when we assemble the report
anything that representative shamberg
has elected to attach to his Minority
Report should be marked in a way where
it's clearly an append appendix to The
Minority Report in other words this
isn't speaking for the majority but I
wonder whether the glossery is actually
helpful or should be excluded if it's
included I think it needs to be made
clear it's part of The Minority Report
because I haven't read it haven't
evaluated it and I think that questions
of the sort that Mr Wong has just
brought up that might just be one
example where we would later wonder
whether we had really comb through this
carefully representative allery yeah
thank you for that and uh just a comment
to representative shanberg we've done
exactly what Mr Wong suggested with
other items in the majority report uh to
to clarify uh and make sure that we were
using consistent language as a matter of
fact our last meeting on uh uh pricing
transfer was based specifically on using
commonly accepted accounting
terms um
just right we're certainly not trying to
create and and introduce
ambiguity I I have no problem with the
using the RSA definition uh the arms
length principle is that ever is that in
the RSA
anywhere
or I think we would lean on federal law
for that Mr Foley
yeah for arms length
482 for uh for the statute from what I
can based on my memory I don't have the
statute in front of me I do not think
that the New Hampshire statute
specifically mentions arms length but it
might make reference to um the Internal
Revenue code that um that would require
arms length am I am I right so again
representive shamberg I I'm unable to
even react to these I haven't read
them but I I
would ask you to consider carefully
whether you really think that they add
to your Minority Report um we're not
waiting into a territory here that you
know where where we're defining the
terms this is uh these are terms that
have been in common usage for decades
and there's plenty of collateral source
for how they should be properly
interpreted so I I would encourage you
to delete them but I leave it to you I
guess there's a way to delete it just
you go like this and then it's off the
page all right well if we can agree to
that that's probably that then we don't
need to look so
closely well that's unfortunate because
a lot of good ammunition in
here then I I'll not make any further
comments on the other parts of the
glossery you're so nice okay all right
thank you fair enough okay I think it's
understood then that they will not be
part of it okay very
good okay
um Jen help me with the process do we do
this as a matter of a formal Vote or uh
or do we just simply uh the members
succeed to the
report
okay okay very good so I'm going to
invite a motion to adopt the commission
report as drafted with the very few
um edits that were U described
verbally Mr chair I would um move to
adopt the report has made with the uh uh
edits and additions made today subject
to scribers review um of the report that
we've made with an attached Minority
Report that is unedited by the board in
total okay thank you for that motion
second second seconded by Senator
Murphy um and uh brief discussion I
would expect to incorporate those edits
into turn it
today and um hasn't had a copy yet well
I mean I think I can incorporate the
edits into something that you can see
online right uh and I assume that we can
then leave it in Jen's hands to make
sure that it's properly
filed with uh the speaker the president
of the Senate Etc by
Wednesday yes
that's yes I meant as a final draft
today to incorporate these edits so that
everyone we get an eyeball on it today
yeah solely to the chair and uh more or
less 24 hours speak now or forever hold
your
peace okay so we have a motion in a
second Mr Foley down there has a
question Mr Foley not not a question but
just um
I'll I'll do a similar thing for the
Society of CPAs just to see if we will
um maybe join Kean with with kind of his
supplemental statement just to confirm
where our stance will be um and I will
communicate with Kevin that that's
ongoing just to see your Mr Kennedy uh
to the extent he feels the obligation to
say the same where we had each been
neutral sure on the recommendations I
just want to clarify that I think that's
fine so I'll be looking in this motion
this vote for um Ascent to the report
adoption of the report and noted that
there may be a caveat coming from either
or both and uh we do have a quorum um
and Mr Kennedy will also be asked to
confirm his asent uh when the redraft is
turned out yes M representative Valerie
we could add that caveat that the the
adoption of this report does not not
recommend um does not indicate approval
of the recommendations merely a
statement of facts of the actions of the
committee as part of as part of the
affirming so that's a suggested way of
going about it I leave it to you yeah I
think that's fair as long as it
preserves um our um dr's neutral
position um we we're not prepared to
vote in any way in terms of um the
recommendations of um adopting or of not
going forward this this is understood
and it's also understood I should point
out that on November
9th uh the way house Ways and Means
Committee will meet uh to deal with its
final three or four uh retained bills
including hp21 and I'm sure the Dr will
be present may be asked to speak so
understood okay I'll get this motion
down right
motion to adopt commission motion to
adopt the commission's report as drafted
with the several
verbal
yes Incorporated
Pati and with minority approach of
report
attached and was there anything else
yeah subject to scribers review what's
that subject subject subject to scribers
review scrier with a V that's
you anything
else and Adoption of this report does
not does
not
reflect use big words have to be small
approbation or affirmation of the
recommendation second no I don't I I
would not include that now you're now
you're altering the motion I think um no
I would leave that out I would let
anybody who wants a
qualifying
addendum to choose their own
wording that's fair too so make simp and
and and and the motion doesn't include
The Minority Report the motion is to
adopt the report of the commission we
all understand that the Minority Report
stands on its own but will be
accompanied okay so the motion does not
include the caveats it does not include
the Minority Report it's the document
we've
goty position
that's not part of the motion that's
not okay right the motion doesn't
include so we're just going with it's to
adopt the commission's report with the
edits that have been
verbally Incorporated okay and we may
then uh collaterally get a qualifying
statement from the Dr Andor the um
CPA
Association is that fair yeah now I got
what you
okay I do believe that was
representative ol's initial motion we've
clarified it we have not amended
it okay I'm gonna call the role Mr
Wong oh yes with with with the qualifier
with those qualifiers thank
you yes thank you yes yes um yes Mr
Young yes yes Senator Murphy yes Mr
Foley
representative
oler representative Shard yes yes yes
Representative shamberg no and uh the
chair votes
yes five days one day thank
you um all right and uh as I said we
will poll Mr Kennedy and add him as an
addendum to the to the Roll Call
um thank you gentlemen I think this has
taken a lot of
patience and I appreciate that everyone
here remain dedicated and in the saddle
right to the end so thank you for that
uh is there anything further that
anybody'd like to say before
we
adjourn
okay Mr chairman I would say that um of
all the commissions and committees I've
sat upon this was the most thorough and
I appreciate the um uh
the dedication and commitment to getting
a very very detailed look at this issue
I certainly learned a lot about it and I
appreciate uh your work and moving
things along well thank you very much I
guess when we look at something once
every 40 years it deserves some
thoroughness all right very good with
that the commission is convened I I mean
is adjourned and that is our last
meeting and uh the report will be filed
by Wednesday thank
you